welcome back to our channel guys i'm sat
here with ryan um ryan moran and ryan
has been a massive inspiration to me
over the last couple of years he is the
founder of capitalism.com he's created a
lot of wealth through several businesses
and i just thought it'd be a great
opportunity to really hear from him and
i don't very often have guests on the
show but sometimes we you can learn a
lot of
a lot of good stuff from other people's
perspectives so ryan firstly thank you
so much for agreeing to come on the on
the show and and and come down and be
interviewed thank you sam i am familiar
with your work i was honored that you
reached out i didn't know that i had
been an inspiration to you over the last
two years so it's an honor and a
privilege to be here and in front of
your crew
amazing so firstly capitalism.com
i mean straight away capitalism has a
lot of
controversial sort of implications with
it i mean i know in britain particularly
um i mean i get um i'm a landlord so i
get a lot of criticism for buying houses
because people think that it's greedy
and i think if you had to link a word to
capitalism most most people the average
person would say greedy capitalist pig
or something like that so firstly what
does capitalism what does it mean to you
and why did you why did you call um your
business capitalism.com
yeah well i bought the domain name for
that reason specifically because it's
controversial and because i
have been very concerned about what that
word means to so many people because
that word what that word means to me is
service
capitalism is the system through which
we serve one another
and we just make agreements with money
we trade our dollars for goods and
services that we need from each other
and it's the way that we incentivize and
prioritize what is most important the
purpose of wealth is for us to fund and
sustain
service to one another and capitalism is
the system through which we do that the
most efficiently and those who do it at
the greatest scale and with the most
efficiency
make the most money because they need
that to sustain that service to one
another
so i've hijacked the name and have
hijacked the meaning because that's what
capitalism is about it just so happens
that when you serve a great number of
strangers at scale that's how you get
rich sam
okay so talk me through then your first
your first business what was what was
what was your first business when did
you realize that you were an
entrepreneur and wanted to make a lot of
money
five years old used to take hand-drawn
computer paper pictures on hand-drawn
computer paper i would draw animals and
i would go door-to-door knocking on
people's door asking them to buy them
for a penny each
my dad was my first customer he bought
two of them so two cents right out of
the gate i made five cents that night
sam
but my dad also supplied all of the
computer paper and the crayons so it was
100 profit 100 margin business 100
profit incredible it was pretty
incredible i've rarely been able to
match those margins from when i was five
i actually wanted to be you when i grew
up i wanted to be a real estate investor
and to be honest with you i'm so excited
to chat with you because i still do
it just so happened that the way i
thought i was going to fund my real
estate ventures was i thought i mean
i'll raise a few bucks online
i was going to school to be a pastor i
expected to make 30 to 35 000 a year and
story for another day but i was doing it
totally out of guilt not out of out of
that's what i wanted to do i wanted to
be an entrepreneur but i thought maybe i
could raise a few bucks online in order
to fund my real estate ventures so when
i graduated high school my friends were
getting
you know
twenty dollars here fifty dollars here
and they were buying books and guitar
amps i thought maybe there's a chance
maybe there's a chance that i could use
this thousand dollars that i got for
graduating high school and i could put
it to work in an internet based business
and and that's what happened i spent the
entire summer building websites learning
search engine optimization i was so
excited to go to college sam because i
would finally have high speed internet i
was building a little business in these
websites from a dial up modem 56k modem
hand coding in raw html i went to
college and had high speed internet and
got learned blogging and email marketing
and all of these great skills which led
me to launch businesses later in life
that i had then either used to make a
profit or to sell
and now i'm actually in that period now
i think i think i'm going to be able to
achieve my childhood dream of of being
like sam and investing in real estate so
finally getting into real estate
how we got there i'm sure you could help
me with some things there well yeah of
course and i think you know what i
really believe that if you want to be in
real estate you need you need you need
two businesses you need a business which
is going to make you fast pound and then
that's producing you cash and then you
then put that money into something
that's going to produce slow pound which
is passive income i've heard you speak
about this as well so i know that i'm uh
preaching to the converted but it's so
huge because if you can't invest in real
estate unless you've got cash
now you can make cash through being a
property entrepreneur which is doing
things like you know
rent to rent and packaging and selling
deals wholesaling but you've chosen to
go down the online um
you know you've chosen to go to the
online route and have absolutely killed
it
in that made millions of pounds and i
think as well every business pretty much
today should be in online business
anyway so whilst i see myself as a as a
property investor i'm very online as
well so the things you talk about seo
and all this stuff it's stuff that i've
had to learn too so talk me through what
is what is an internet business i know
you've helped thousands of people also
set up um internet businesses so what
does that even mean an internet business
isn't every business an internet
business
uh
close today yes
but but the way that i have helped
hundreds of people build million dollar
businesses which is kind of my claim to
fame where i'm really strong what i do
better than anyone else in the world is
i can give pretty much anyone the road
map to having an a million dollar online
business and sam it's basic math it's
third grade math it looks like this if
you have four products that sell 25
sales a day that's a hundred sales a day
and at a thirty dollar price point
that's three thousand dollars a day in
sales
over the course of a year is about 1.1
million dollars and so what i help
people do is i help them plug in the
pieces of that formula what are your
four products going to be how do we get
them to 25 sales a day and let's
maintain a 30 price point at least at
minimum and hopefully we can work up
from there
and that allows my students and the
people who follow me to have a clear
road map to building a million dollar
business and then they can take those
profits and put them into real estate as
they probably should but the beauty of
the model of building a business versus
just having a blog or doing seo or
having clients
is when you have a real business that
sells real stuff to real people that is
a business that can be sold
so i was i was actually talking with a
friend of mine
who said there are only two people in
this world who have this game figured
out it's the e-commerce people and it's
the real estate people because they're
the only people that have the ability to
have income and work towards an exit i
thought that was a really interesting
comparison so they were saying your
world and my world is the only place
where they can get this and
probably both really i mean if you can
do both then
and and i think as well focus is really
important and i've heard you speak about
focus and if you try and chase every
shiny penny you know you'll end up
you'll end up catching nothing
but at the same time i think having
again having a fast pound business and a
slow pound business that run alongside
one another i think is a great model to
have and if you look at the sunday times
rich list in the uk there's a lot of
folks that have got a trading business
and then a real estate business um and i
think that model really works so talk to
me then about your first you you said
you had your first business or your
first when you first started
entrepreneur you were a kid what was
your
when did you make your first million how
did you make your first million what was
the product
yeah so i i made my first first my first
six figures first six figures a year
blogging and doing affiliate marketing
and this is where i started to develop
the skill set
of
managing websites building websites
selling websites realizing that these
digital businesses could be scaled and
sold realizing people were flipping them
all day long you could buy content sites
or you could buy affiliate marketing
sites you could buy all of these small
tiny websites get them profitable and
sell them well that was really
interesting
but where i made my first million sam
was when i finally said it's time for me
to have a real business is that it's
like i make my cash doing taking on
clients or doing email copywriting or
selling affiliate products that's all
great it's all fine but in the same way
that you say you need to have your slow
cash and your fast cash for me i was
making lots of fast cash
to the tune of a six figure six figure
amount in my 20s which was amazing but i
did not have the slow part of it which
is why i got into this game in the first
place
so i wanted something that i could build
and sell someday and that's what led me
to sell physical stuff the beauty i call
it the perfect business because
the the physical product once you send
it to their house you're done you've
fulfilled all of your obligations you
make it once and you can sell it an
infinite number of times
now i was a new dad but she's now six
and a half but my daughter had just been
born
and i was starting to develop the early
stages of a dad bod
and so i started what i call the
anti-dad bod plan where i went on this
journey of being a really fit dad and
during that adventure i realized that
there were a bunch of supplements and a
bunch of foods and a bunch of behaviors
that i took on that i didn't have before
it was things like drinking pre-workouts
or taking creatines or taking a
testosterone booster or a sleep
supplement and i started to notice that
i was interested in all these things and
i developed a line of products that i
wanted that match that same desire and
so the first step that i walk people
through when i'm talking about
businesses you first choose your
customer who is it that you're serving
in my case
new dad in his 20s
who wanted to be fit
and then the second step what are the
four products that person buys right out
of the gate and for me protein powder
pre-workout testosterone booster sleep
supplement multivitamin and on and on
and on it goes
and so i started following that formula
based on exactly what was going on in my
life i choose my person
i choose those four products that i
would buy as that person
and then we work together to 25 sales a
day it took a year 12 months to have
that business selling a million dollars
a year and at that point my partner and
i looked at each other and said i think
we got something here and so that was
the first million it was also the first
10 million and then we sold that
business when it was doing about 10
million dollars a year so that was the
first million and how we got it so
that's like a health health and fitness
type business then but online
it was i also started a few other
companies at that time i had a yoga
products business that i sold after
about a year of running it it was just
good timing but that same formula of
four products 25 sales a day
it applies to all spaces and a lot of
our students use it in yoga or they use
it in food or they use it in swimming or
they use it in whatever hobby or passion
they're about and then they apply that
formula to make it a business so
interesting that the the kind of the
foundation of that was creating the
product right but you created a product
based on what you thought you wanted
that's right so it's like what would i
what do i want i'm a little bit
overweight i've got a dad bard what do i
want and then you and then you create a
product that's almost a great product
for you and then you think okay well how
can i now market that and find other
people because if i wanted other people
well and i think that's a really and
again in any business you can transfer
that like one of the one of the things
that i'm where i actually made my first
million um the strategy and it started
off i i started it in buy to let buying
properties however made my first million
was packaging investments
and selling those investments to other
investors
and
and and i think you know when i was
thinking
when i was thinking okay i'm gonna start
selling deals to other investors i was
selling them deals that i wanted but i
couldn't afford them so i was finding
property investments that i wanted but i
couldn't afford to necessarily buy an
unlimited amount of them or even i did
buy something similar i'm like man this
property is so good but there's lots
others like that but i can only afford
to buy one so why don't i
package the others and sell them and get
a fee and i you know i did that i sold
hundreds of of deals um and became a
millionaire by age 25 and that was sort
of my first product so again similar in
terms of creating a product that you
want for yourself and then packaging it
and selling it to uh you know to other
people
you know what's funny is you probably
called what you did wholesaling it was
kind of wholesaling on steroids kind of
a little different but
it's very it's similar so wholesaling is
when you lock a price and get paid the
difference whereas what i'm doing is i'm
just finding an opportunity
and negotiating the price i'm never
owning it i'm never and then i'm just
passing the opportunity on somebody yeah
and the very interesting crossover here
is in the physical product space it's
almost the same where we're creating a
product we're creating something that we
want and then we're just selling that at
scale to thousands or millions of people
you had a one-to-one model which was
your fast cash and it's kind of the same
in the e-commerce or physical products
world as you make the product once and
then you list it for sale and you're not
the one making the product you have a
manufacturer that's making the product
and then it's being shipped by amazon or
by shopify or your fulfillment house so
it actually is a very similar mindset
for that quick cash method or for that
cash flow business that you can then
parlay into real estate or your other
ventures question then for you ryan do
you think that do you think that people
are born entrepreneurs or do you or do
you think or do you think they're made
because you told me you had your first
business at five
same as me i started out young you know
as a teenager doing paper rounds um
are entrepreneurs born or entrepreneurs
made what do you reckon
i think it's the exact same as an
athlete some athletes are born with the
physical makeup for being an athlete but
they don't necessarily become athletes
until that skill is until that craft is
is created until they are working hard
to hone that craft entrepreneurs are
exactly the same you can have the
natural skill set of an entrepreneur but
you are not that
until that is owned and in the same way
you could be born without the raw
ingredients and outwork everybody else
and become a successful athlete mugsy
bogues was you know 5'3 or whatever he
was and he was still an all-star
basketball player whereas in the same
way in entrepreneurship you cannot have
all of the raw ingredients and still be
very successful the the beauty about
entrepreneurship though is there are
lots and lots of ways to play the game
so i do think that you can be born with
natural skill sets that help you succeed
in the marketplace but because
entrepreneurship is a custom path you're
creating the game you're defining the
rules of this game you can build the
business around whatever your craft is
whatever you are best at for example i
am a natural communicator i love to
write i love to speak i if there's a
camera put me in front of it if there's
a stage put me on it sam that is what i
love to do it's my natural skill and so
i've built a business with
my average entrepreneurship skills i've
built that around what my real craft is
my real ability to connect with other
people and to communicate so
entrepreneurship you are born with some
raw skills
but most of the craft is built
throughout your life based on the things
that you practice and the skills that
you amplify that's what i think about
that sam i think that's i think that's a
really good answer i think so so
basically it's a bit of both and if
you've got the natural ability as well
that will take you so far but you need
training and mentors and hard work and
craft and skill and dedication but if
you are uh born with no entrepreneurial
flair whatsoever and you're 47 years old
and you're working a nine to five it's
not too late for you because you can
still become a great entrepreneur with
the right persistence and dedication
well let me let me say something to what
you just said there since you said 47
you can still become an entrepreneur i
have a student who in his early 40s
he he bought one of my trainings back in
2013
2013 sam i was new at this game and i
said hey i'm going on a new journey here
a new adventure i don't know how it's
going to go but i'm creating a small
little mastermind for us to go through
it together
and he was on my email list and he
bought whatever it was it was like 2500
bucks or something and he was the first
person to buy
and i called him up and we had a nice
little chat for a few minutes and he had
just lost
everything
he had just had his his last business
went under he had a terrible breakup
with his partners he had lost all of his
money he had been disgraced by his
family
and i helped mentor this guy for about
the first two years of his business in
his early 40s but then we lost touch sam
and i didn't hear from him for several
years
one day uh in 2020 i opened up an
investment fund for e-commerce
businesses that come from my audience my
book's been pretty successful my
podcast's been pretty successful and so
i have deal flow from a lot of
businesses that are interesting to me
and i raised a fund to invest in them
and he invested in the fund which was
awesome but you know i also didn't know
that he had been successful enough to
invest in this fund right we had lost
touch for a few years so he kind of came
out of the woodwork invested in the fund
and he came to the first meetup now
remember this is a man who had lost
everything in his in his early to mid
40s and was starting completely over
learning from a kid who was
28 29 at the time
and we lost touch he shows up at my
house for the first fund meetup
and he looks me in the eye and he says
hey did i ever tell you what happened
with your brand or with with his brand
and i said no i mean i assume it was
modestly successful you're here
and he said well i i had a nine-figure
exit i sold it for over a hundred
million dollars oh geez over 100 million
dollars again
was had nothing
in his early to mid-40s he's like
43-45-ish
so you can screw everything up yeah yeah
yeah into your 40s
and then have something hit
and be and be just fine
and all of that prepared him perfectly
for that opportunity it's huge ryan nine
figure
i've experienced
my own set of setbacks especially in the
last two years
covid
everybody had a hard time in the last
two years covet hit some of my
businesses i had a restaurant back in
ohio that i closed it hit some of my
other businesses that were not directly
related to what i'm talking about today
so like it's like i have to remind
myself of this too you know i'm 34 and
sometimes you think like man gotta get i
gotta get a move on gotta i gotta hurry
up
and so remembering some of those stories
of people who
didn't start until their 40s
it reminds me how much time we have i
have a an acquaintance his name is
trevor blake he had a great book called
three simple steps trevor blake was not
an entrepreneur at all
until his mid-40s
and then he had three nine-figure exits
in his first 10 years
hundreds of millions of dollars in those
10 years because
he had the maturity the network
and with the readiness for then it to
hit i love stories like that you know
what those were i see a lot of people
making a lot of money
these days
with bitcoin and and
stuff like that
and it kind of sometimes almost worries
me
when when someone because i i meet these
these kids you know they're like oh i
just made quarter of a million pounds
because
i don't feel like they've actually got
the where with all the resilience
to actually make money and run a
business and obviously i'm really
pleased for them it's great but
sometimes i just think man
when that 250 thousand pounds goes or
whatever maybe you'll make continue to
make loads and that's fine but i know if
you drop them butt naked
in this in the middle of in the middle
of london
with nothing
then they wouldn't have they wouldn't
have a i mean i've done that many times
as a social experiment i've literally
just gone
locked myself off from my contacts and
dropped myself in the middle of nowhere
i've done it like seven times
just just to prove to myself i've still
got it man yeah you know just to prove
to myself you can drop me and it makes
me just think i don't care if i lose any
everything if i'm in a caravan
tomorrow and i've lost all of my
millions and i've got nothing
actually you know what it doesn't matter
and so many people right now are scared
because of the pandemic and everything
that's gone on and then i'm super
worried about what but it's like hang on
if you're a real entrepreneur and you
know how to make money and you know how
to add value and you know how to sell
and you know how to market and you know
then you never have to worry about
anything ever again if you made 250 000
pounds on bitcoin
i mean good for you man but that that
that doesn't really mean anything about
your character or your resilience so
it's just interesting the way people but
maybe i'm maybe i'm wrong maybe i'll
maybe maybe i'm missing something well
sam i think money is a lot like alcohol
it just amplifies whoever you are
if you give a generous person
a couple of drinks
it doesn't take long until they're just
giving money away until they become they
become a car for you and money for you
it makes them more of who they are if
you get an extrovert who loves the
camera if you give me a couple of drinks
i don't get quiet okay i want to be the
life of the party sam and money is
exactly the same way yeah if you give a
person who's insecure
250 000 pounds
and they made it in bitcoin chances are
they're actually more scared inside
if you give somebody who is
who is short-sighted has short-term
thinking you give them a lot of money
they will waste it on short-term things
so money is an amplifier it it may it
makes who we are louder
and so this is why i say
entrepreneurship is the greatest
self-development program on the planet
because all of your flaws get exposed
when there's money and then you're the
one left
with yourself your skill set and what
you do next
and so i i don't i don't get worried
about all the people making money in
bitcoin or whatever it is i do wonder
who they will become
i do wonder how it will impact who they
become and how it will help them evolve
because we're all evolving we're all
changing hopefully for the better and i
think a lot of the fast money that
you're seeing move right now is just
accelerating that process
yeah no i think you're right and i think
i think i i guess um
you know if you've if you've built
something up though if you've built a
business up you can build it again
if you've made money in bitcoin can you
do it again if you lose it i i don't
know you know i know i know that the
strategies that i do and i teach and
i've done it for years i could just keep
doing it over and over um what about you
if if you were stripped naked and
dropped in a random state and you had
nothing and you you know no no
connections um
you know no money
just your knowledge and your experience
what's the first steps what are you
gonna do what's the what's your first
seven days gonna look like you know the
the first thing that i always tell
students who are starting over again and
i still go i still do this process every
single time and that a reset or in a new
chapter or i feel like i'm starting over
is i make a list of 10 people in my life
that i want to be around more in this
next chapter now if you lose your
connections in this experiment sam then
you'd have to go meet 10 people first
that would be step one
but once you've got 10 people who you
know this is the person who drives a
nice car and goes to your church this is
the person who is well a
well-established community member that
owns a business in town these are the
people within your network or within
your sphere of influence that you'd like
to be around more often
and i drop them a handwritten thank you
card and it follows a little template
the template always goes something like
this hey so-and-so i just wanted to let
you know how you've impacted my life as
a result of watching you do x y and z
i've made the decision to start my own
business go out on my own or whatever it
is that you're deciding to do
i'm so thankful that you did x y and z
and if i can ever be a resource for you
i would consider it a privilege thanks
so much sign your name and what that
does is it starts to build the network
and then when that person inevitably
reaches out to you and says thanks for
the card meet them up for coffee get on
a phone call go see them whatever it is
and always ask about them what are they
up to what are their mindsets what are
their beliefs and i've never made it all
the way down 10 people and not had new
opportunities
open up for me because when they
inevitably turn it around to you and say
what's going on with you you just say
i'm in transition i'm looking for my
next thing i've never had that not lead
to new opportunities and in all business
it comes down to connections and your
ability to serve other people so that's
why my process always starts with okay
i'm gonna start with who are the people
how do i connect with them and then how
do i think about serving them rather
than myself and that always breeds
results it always brings in
opportunities and then you work really
hard you work like hell at those
opportunities wherever they lead you so
my answer is not i would start investing
in real estate in that area or that i
would start another e-commerce business
or i'd start blogging again although i
would probably document every single
step of my turnaround period my answer
is i would find the connections in that
state or in that part of town and then i
would start building that network and
start giving to those people and then
yes i would probably start a blog and
document the whole thing which would
make my network build that that much
faster yeah no that's really interesting
so it's kind of almost
tapping into other people's businesses
and what they've got seen how you can
serve um
one of the things i really believe is i
believe that a a good relationship is
always better than a good deal
and even even even in real estate you
know sometimes um i'll be going to are
we going to view a property and
i might think is that property actually
the best is that the best is this going
to be the best investment but i think
you know what i'm not viewing a property
i've got an appointment with a real
estate agent right now and even if the
property sucks having an opportunity to
share with them why it sucks and what
i'm actually looking for and what could
be better
they'll probably end up saying oh
actually come down the road with me 15
minutes let me show you this it's just
about it's just about getting in front
of people and letting people know what
you're looking for and what you're about
and what you're trying to do rather than
trying to actually find rather than
chasing the money it's about trying to
build those you know connections i i'm
so glad you said that because if if we
thought as an entrepreneurial community
if we thought more about
service
rather than systems
we would grow so much faster we love to
obsess about what's the best way to
invest in real estate or what's the best
way to sell my product on amazon or
what's the best system to make a hundred
thousand dollars a year working no more
than 10 hours a week we prioritize those
and we obsess over those but the real
answer is
the best system is through serving other
people yes you're having a core group of
people that we are in service to whether
it is agents or it is tenants or it is
customers the person who serves the most
makes the most that is the best system
but that comes back to
what we started talking about beginning
which is capitalism because that's what
capitalism is yes it is and that's why
when people get upset with me
for
buying a house and breaking it up room
by room oh you're ruined it's like hang
on
hang on
my house is my product and my tenant is
my customer so when in real estate which
is a business you need to think what do
people want
people want affordable accommodation
they don't want big
so okay so i'm gonna buy a house break
it up and give people what they want and
as a result of giving people what they
want i'm gonna get paid for it
which is what capitalism in in its
essence and i'll tell you something
really interesting as well i know you're
interested in debates and stuff but i
have tried so hard to have somebody come
on my youtube channel
and have a really healthy debate
about capitalism versus communism oh
invite me next time sam i have a really
high conversion rate on turning people
from uh communist and socialists into
capitalists invite you next time but
i've never had a single person that's
agreed
to have the conversation
oh never
i've never ever ever and there's there's
whole channels you know there's whole
channels where they will say they're
communists or socialists and um and
that's great and i don't necessarily
think they're bad people at all i think
they probably have got in some ways very
similar values to me and probably would
to you but i just fundamentally disagree
with their logic
um but no they they they'll it they'll
never they'll never come on the show but
i think it's uh it's just interesting so
sam i i think we could collab on this i
think between our collective networks we
can make this happen if you're watching
this on youtube on sam's channel and you
want to see this debate happen
let us know in the comments and we'll
find a way to collab on this one we'll
make this happen it would be great
because i would i'd love to i think the
best way to learn is to debate
and sometimes in fact sometimes i'll
have a really strong opinion and then
i've had someone go i want to debate you
on that and then i'm like whoa hold on
let me just really research this
properly now because it's all good
having an opinion until you have to
debate it live on youtube and then you
research properly and come with the
facts you know i was having i had a
debate with i had a debate with somebody
last year about rent control which is
um should our mayor sadiq khan should
the mayor of london um cap rent because
the londoners were
in fact in new york they did this in new
york they capped rents and they said
rents can't go up a certain amount and
it absolutely distorted the market it
ruins the housing market out in new york
and um you know i was like rent
control's ridiculous you should have a
willing buyer and a willing seller
trying to control the renters and then
someone said i'll debate you on that and
then suddenly i was like whoa i need to
think this through now really serious
and i came to the conclusion of i i
didn't change my mind but i had a much
stronger more well thought through
balanced articulated opinion which is a
really good thing so you debate a lot
about politics and religion and all
kinds of stuff um you know what what is
it what is it that makes you enjoy doing
the debate so much well sam first of all
here is how you know you're ready to
debate something
when you can give
a thoughtful argument for both sides and
someone else can't tell where you stand
on it
that's how you know you're ready to
debate so i love the fact that the first
thing that you did when someone
challenged you to a debate is go study
their side of it yeah and that that
gives you the firepower to be able to
overcome a lot of their beliefs and
their objections
so when you can argue this is this is
where i think as a society we have it so
wrong this side is yelling this side
tries to yell louder this side marches
and this side riots and it becomes a
shouting match and no one is listening
to one another the way we bridge the
deba the the divide especially in a
debate is by building bridges that look
like listening to one another and when
someone feels heard they are very likely
to be persuaded
if you can brid go over the bridge to
their side of the argument and truly
understand it hear where they are coming
from
then they are more likely to be
persuaded not all the time but much more
likely that's how you change minds so
what i love about the debate process
whether it's about politics or it's for
its religion
is because most people just yell
where i have a unique skill set is being
willing to come over to the other side
and understand where they're coming from
understand that side of the debate and
that's why i'm very confident in my
ability to persuade people because of
the empathy that is there
right now we say that we're divided like
the right and the left or the democrats
and the republicans or whatever what
picket we say we live in a divided world
i say we have higher demand for unity
than ever
and so i like to go into the middle
and i like to build bridges there and
debates are a fun way for me to do that
because i think there are very few
people right now who are willing to
build bridges yeah that's interesting so
so i'm gonna have to write that one down
what did you say you said um we're that
we're not divided more than ever we are
we have higher demand for unity than
ever
we don't like being divided
we don't we don't like the shouting
matches we just think it's the other
side's fault yeah
we don't like that there's a divide
between us but most people will say well
the reason we're divided is because they
are x y z
but they don't realize that they're
doing it right now when you say they
when you say it's their fault you are
now
creating two teams that is the divide
so the way through that
is to go over and understand
is to go is to have empathy is to build
that bridge and then you are persuasive
then you then you can be heard seek ye
first to understand
only then can you be understood
yes great and and that's why i love the
debate process it's an opportunity for
me
to flex that muscle and to do my part in
bridging the divide yeah love that and
and again when you're debating the
purpose of a debate is not to win right
the purpose of a debate is is to learn
and to grow and to develop
um you've got an interesting take as
well i know the last couple of years has
been crazy um in fact in fact the last
few years just generally in in in the
united states but also across the world
we've had we've had the uh the pandemic
which is everybody uh you know lockdowns
i think the uk is probably
one of the lastest countries in the
world right now though there's no
math squaring you just lifted all the
restrictions right completely lifted
no math squaring no social distance in
in fact as from next month even if you
catch covered you don't have to
self-isolate so we've like literally
lifted pretty much completely
that's caused a lot of division or has
it or has it caused a higher demand for
unity
i think that creates a higher
need for personal responsibility which
is what we needed in the first place
what do you mean
when when you have the ruling of there's
no more restrictions
now we are not relying on rules to keep
us safe yeah we are now relying on
personal responsibility of making good
decisions
and deciding what is best for us and our
families which is what is usually the
solution to most problems people taking
personal responsibility for their impact
on their family and their impact on
their communities as well what i see
from the perspective of the founder of
capitalism.com
what i see happening is we are seeing
the ineptitude of government in full
display we are seeing the
problem of what happens when you give
government too much control
and the fallout that happens
and we do this across the board i mean
republicans gave trump unheard of power
and he used it
and now that pendulum is swinging and
the democrats those on the left have
that same power that we gave to
republican presidents and they're able
to use it
now what happens when government has too
much power is they mess things up
they spend into incredible deficits they
print too much money they create
programs that don't work
and what i think we are seeing right now
is we are seeing on full display how
that ends up and it looks like
the public institutions failing
the reason why bitcoin and
cryptocurrency
has taken off so much in the last two
years is because it's the first
privatization of something that was
previously controlled by governments
money supply and currency
now i was a bitcoin doubter until 2020.
why is that
because 2020 was the final nail in the
coffin of seeing how
governments use and manipulate money
and so they increase demand for there to
be a bitcoin like alternative and i'm
not married to it being bitcoin or any
other cryptocurrency but bitcoin seems
to be winning and that is a response to
poor government policy
and this happens throughout history we
see governments get control
and then that breaks apart and you have
private institutions come up and they
be a better way forward we're going to
see that in health care next we have
private health care organizations
creating
solutions to diseases that have plagued
us for centuries now be on the cusp of
being affordable for the masses and
being done with the what the the
advances that are happening in things
like gene sequencing and gene editing
that can literally just edit out
diseases
is coming from the private markets that
could never happen
with just government oversight and so we
see these opportunities and these
transitions throughout time where
government is in control they mess
things up they drop the ball and
entrepreneurs and capitalists pick up
the ball and they run with it and we're
seeing that across the board on full
display at an accelerated rate right now
because of the failures of government
over the last two years and so i am
extremely optimistic right now sam i'm
extremely optimistic not because i want
governments to fail and not because i
want us to go through growing pains but
because i know that capitalism works
because i know that even if you
try to restrict freedom that freedom is
a more powerful force so if you try to
restrict freedom it just increases the
demand and the momentum for there to be
more freedom if you restrict people's
ability to trade through socialism or
capitalism it just increases the demand
and the desire for people to voluntarily
trade it's just like if you restrict
speech you will get people protesting
and yelling even louder you cannot
restrict freedom for a long period of
time you can push it back slightly and
try to hold the line but eventually that
breaks because the demand for freedom
and capitalism and entrepreneurship and
creation is too strong and so i think we
are about to enter a new golden age of
creation and opportunity and capitalism
that will be faster and cheaper and more
accessible to everyone than ever before
and so i think we have fanned the flames
of the desire and the need for unity and
capitalism and kindness and empathy and
i am very optimistic about where that
leads yeah that's great really really
powerful and interesting and you know i
think i i think i wholeheartedly agree
with you actually um
and
when the government dropped the ball
that's when that's when we rise up
entrepreneurs have to rise up and um
interesting what you said about private
private health care as well so i think
um see we have the nhs in in in britain
and uh it's interesting as well with
capitalism because
if you're an absolute all out capitalist
where does that leave things like
regulation
minimum wage like do you believe do you
believe in minimum wage
i i think that the minimum wage should
not be raised
i think that i have an economics
background um and so did quite a bit of
studying into minimum wage and kind of
the the most effective way in my opinion
to have a minimum wage is to have a
minimum wage that is below market rate
so you can have a minimum wage as long
as it's below market rate meaning people
aren't laid off at all as a result of
there being a minimum wage
if someone wants to accept
a wage that is less than
minimum
there should be a private agreement
between employer and employee of course
it's marketed as something that is a
protection for employees but i actually
think it creates more harm
so you don't really believe in anyone
you don't really believe in it at all
then do you if you think that
they could they could have a private
agreement where you can work below them
i'm running for office i'm not running
on a campaign of getting rid of the
minimum wage right it's like i don't
think we need a massive overhaul i think
on our list of problems it's like 37th
yeah if it's that high it's interesting
though it's an interesting point what
would happen if there was no minimum
wage at all if it was a complete free
market be interested to see whether that
would end up being a good thing or or a
bad thing this is what would happen
some people would fall through the
cracks
but most people would work harder would
create more would be more incentivized
to have personal responsibility and the
wealth that would be created could then
be given be given to private
organizations that take care of those
who fall through the cracks yeah this is
another area in which personal
responsibility is more effective than
government and with government we we tax
the money take 50 and try to create the
safety net that is inefficient and
bloated
but if
individuals
were
putting that money into private
organizations instead
you would have a much deeper wider
kinder more empathetic
security blanket that safety net would
be much stronger because the
incentives to take care of one another
are much stronger on a one-to-one basis
than on a national level and again it's
like you know
if we rely on the government to look
after people if we think it's the
government's job to look after the poor
and to look after then then
the job doesn't really get done and i
think we've cut i like what you said
about kindness as well you see i believe
in capital but i consider myself a
compassionate capitalist a kind
capitalist someone that free market but
cares about the people um so that you
know communism says that communism says
that the people are too dumb and stupid
to have the money let's give it to the
state let's give it to the government
and just trust that they distribute it
something that actually um
an analogy i use to people that don't
really understand capitalism and aren't
sure
is i i'll say imagine if you had a
school
and the school said it's not fair that
some of the pupils
are getting a stars
and some are getting f's
and the ones that get f's haven't then
got the same opportunity as the kids
that guy starts so what we're going to
do is we're going to give everyone their
exams and then we're going to add up
everyone's grade
and we're going to divide it amongst the
people amongst the number of pupils of
the school so that way everybody in
theory
should get a c and that's this is the
thing in theory everyone should get c
but what happened is
the kids weren't being incentivized to
even try so suddenly the 8 stars will
just be like oh wow
whatever i'm just going to get this is
all going to be pulled together so so it
kills ambition and actually the standard
of the grade goes down significantly for
everybody and in the same way with
communism if we if we say let's just add
up all the money give it to the
government let them distribute it well
even if the government did distribute it
fairly which they wouldn't and
historically don't but even if they did
distribute it fairly and evenly amongst
the people you've just killed
entrepreneurship there isn't enough
there isn't enough that money money goes
around you've got to be a reservoir so
you know i think um people hopefully if
people can't understand that then i
don't really i don't really understand
um what what else really to say other
than that business is good and
money follows value and entrepreneurs
being encouraged and championed
surely is a great thing so i'm not sure
how much i'm not sure how much of it
might come from um people just being
upset or jealous that they haven't got
money and wishing ah i wish that the
government just took it off them and
gave it to me it comes from fear
it comes from fear and our lack of
confidence that we can produce
it comes from the fear of being
controlled the fear of a loss of freedom
it comes from the fear of thinking i'm
not gonna be okay
and i don't have the confidence that i
can produce
unfortunately when you rely on
government to fix that problem you never
solve the wound
that's why personal responsibility is at
the crux of capitalism because personal
responsibility for you to improve at
your skill set for you to create more
for you to take responsibility for the
results that you create for you to be in
service to other people that is the crux
of capitalism whereas when you just have
government intervention come in and
solve the problem you disincentivize
personal responsibility which creates
less ability for people to grow and give
and serve and so you perpetuate the
problem rather than solving it the real
solution is more capitalism more freedom
more entrepreneurship it's going on that
journey of the best personal development
tool on the planet which is taking a
risk and becoming an entrepreneur and
creating something and going out in the
marketplace and being told no
and then adjusting and getting beaten up
a little bit and getting better and
improving and being committed
to your own growth
we disincentive
when i was in um 2018 i was in uganda
and i had a really serious accident i
fell down i fell down a waterfall broke
my leg
serious serious accident and i went down
to the hospital got taken to the
hospital and the ugandan hospital this
is you know developing a developing
country
and they said to me before we'll even
look at your leg or anything
what how much money you got because
you're gonna you know you're gonna have
to and for me
that's not in in the uk we have the
national health service we have the nhs
and um i remember thinking you know i'm
really grateful for the for the nhs
because there was people that were
coming into the hospital in uganda that
were being sent away because they didn't
have enough money and some of them were
in a far worse worst state than i was
and had car accidents really bad way
just being sent away from hospitals
basic human needs weren't being met
because they didn't have the money um
so you know in england we have we have
the mhs service which is
a welcome to anyone even if you're even
if you're a foreigner even if you're an
illegal immigrant if you fall down and
are sick or get hit by a car they take
you and they'll treat you and give you
the you know the the um the care that
you need um
but
presumably you're not you're not really
you don't think that's a good concept
you're not a fa in favor of of the of an
nhs
i'm not an expert in how the nhs works
or in
economics yeah i know obviously a lot
more about how it works where i live
but i do know but but i do consider
myself well-versed in economics and
basic economics says that the incentives
are greater when the numbers are smaller
when the focus is smaller for example
i am more incentivized to care about
what's going on in my community
than in three states away or three
countries away so the more that you can
keep the focus on the local level or on
the community level or the private level
the higher the quality the lower the
costs the faster the speed the easier in
which we can get everyone in agreement
on something
so when we turn over government when we
turn over health care to government
control
you can have what we call equity which
means everyone gets it but you do not
have quality you have lesser quality
so charlie munger has an interesting
take on this his his belief is that you
can have a very base level government
plan
that gets removed as the market creates
more efficiencies
so if you have the ability if you have
the willingness the gojones to reduce
government involvement as the
marketplace creates more incentives and
more products and lower costs then
government can be a pacifying
a pacifying system it can have the
ability to create
new benefits and spearhead things it can
have that ability
the trouble comes in when we are
resistant to reducing that or removing
that as the market creates new programs
so this is where i disagree with some of
my colleagues and
the the capitalist side of things where
they think there should be no government
at all i think government can lead the
way
with areas where the marketplace is not
yet as efficient as long as you are
willing to back that up over time
we in the states are terrible at this i
hope that you are better at this because
you're working with a a more localized
area right so with the united states we
have 400 million people across 3 000
miles to come up with one system that
fits everyone would be a disaster but if
you look at states that have their own
systems individually
they're very popular within their own
states
so you can have a system in which each
state has their own program that goes
smaller and smaller over time as the
marketplace creates
more more products and services but if
you were to create a national healthcare
service here in the states it would
crumble because there's too many people
there's too many different cultures here
there's it's over too wide span of of a
square mile area and so you don't have
the same incentives this is why in my
opinion the uk is able to do it much
more efficiently than us but either way
i think that you should be able to
reduce the size of government as the
marketplace gets more efficient yeah
what what are the taxes like in texas
well thankfully in texas we have no
state income tax but we are just ripped
apart with property taxes now this is
okay with me because in in economics
property taxes are the least bad type of
tax and and i like
i i like for people to feel how much tax
they are paying because now they have an
incentive to push back against them and
property tax is one of those where you
feel it directly you feel it because
you're paying it every month or every
year you write a check
and it doesn't go away for as long as
you live there if your income comes down
you are still paying the property tax
and so property tax is one of the lesser
bad taxes because it's felt the most
which means that people will push back
against it the most
but zero income tax in texas zero income
tax on the state level we still of
course have federal
federal taxes yeah but we don't have a
we do not have an income tax in texas
see it's interesting how in
in america the taxes are so different
from state to state like in california i
mean uh grant cardone who you know i'm a
good friend of grant moved stay over he
moved he moved to miami just for taxes
which is really interesting concept
um
you know so um california i think just
raised theirs so like 22
22
on top of
of federal taxes which are already 36 or
38
i mean pretty much pretty much that
when you just when you just about
understand taxes and you understand how
many times you get taxed from how many
different angles it is something and i
like playing taxes i've got no i think
paying taxes is is a good thing i think
they're putting putting a percentage of
of what what you earn aside because i
believe in the nhs and things like that
what i don't agree with is where they'll
say you should just take away so much
that it just it you know means what's
the point of even
of even trying to run a business but i'm
very happy to pay taxes um but um
you need to understand tax if you're as
an entrepreneur you need to understand
how to not evade it but how to be
creative and um
especially to delay it
because as entrepreneurs
we are taxed more than anyone
and entrepreneurs need as much dry
powder as possible to go spearhead the
next chapter
entrepreneurs do not have the security
blanket that other people have we're
putting everything on our backs and
saying hey follow me yeah so
entrepreneurs need to at least know how
to delay taxes to a later date i always
say the best time to pay taxes is later
always later
if you can defer it if you can delay it
to free up room and capital now
i think that's a good idea and the
reason that's a good idea is because
there will be different incentives and
different loopholes and different new
tax programs later that you can take
advantage of when the government wants
to incentivize a certain behavior i have
a friend his name is tom wheelwright
he's kind of the the
all right cool he's like the most famous
cpa in the world he's like the elvis of
taxes right
and he will tell you that that taxes are
simply an incentive structure yeah
the tax code is there to incentivize
certain behaviors why do we incentivize
real estate investing because people
need homes
and people need safe secure homes that
are affordable yeah so we incentivize
real estate investing to create more
competition
in real estate investing to drive down
costs for individuals yeah why do we
have
some tax
tax havens for businesses because we
want more products and services
so we incentivize the things that create
the most value if you have a government
that is actually trying to grow and so
knowing the tax code is not just about
protecting what you've earned it's also
to find out where there are incentives
that make society grow or at least what
the government says yes
our incentives are absolutely then using
that as a guiding light for where we
make decisions yeah absolutely bang i
like electric cars you know they're
wanting to drive electric cars i don't
know about in the states yes in uk 100
tax deductible 100
if you drive electric we just got an
electric car mercedes eqc because it's
completely tax deductible um even in
real estate it's interesting because in
real estate they've taxed the heck out
of property investors over the last few
years
but there's loopholes if you're doing
property investing in a certain way if
you're buying through a company and if
you're in other words if you're doing
the right kind of property investing in
the way that they want
then it's fine but if you're an amateur
and you're not doing it through a
company and you're that then then
suddenly you're going to get taxed to
high heavens and you need to understand
the incentives of how they want you to
which presumably is going to mean that
you're doing it better you're adding to
society and as a result you're paying
less taxes everyone's a winner so when
people get really mad about rich people
not paying much taxes actually it's
because we're just doing what the
government wants us to do and following
the incentives that's exactly right and
you don't get a bigger base of taxes
without more good capitalists without
people creating more
and working within the system to be able
to follow those incentives and paying
tax on those profits so you can hate on
capitalist entrepreneurs but they're the
ones driving change both privately and
publicly yeah
who um who's would you say influence you
the most but um at the same event where
i met grant
i met gary vaynerchuk
and i
never expected to be so influenced by a
man that i was so surprised by he was
not what i expected him to be when he
was off stage he was kind and humble and
present and this is back in the crush at
days when he was like go go go crush it
kill it he wasn't as big as he was now
but i found his presence and his focus
and his kindness
completely captivating and ever since
then i have been a a disciple of gary's
having dinner with him in april i will
do whatever i can to be around the man
he's 12 years my senior 12 years ahead
of me and i am
very
um
i am i am very compelled
by his kindness and his empathy and the
way that he creates
that type of of value for the world so
he inspires me to be better hmm that's
great i like gary i've met gary as well
a couple times i went to his um oh
what's it called 4d
yeah where it is yeah i went to one of
his four days so spent a little bit of
time with him and yeah nice guy although
i'd say something interesting about
grant
when i first met grant because i know
grant quite well um when i first met
grant
after watching his videos and seeing him
you know he's very aggressive on stage
and he's you know heavy and sell sell
sell i assumed i'm gonna learn a lot
from him but he's probably going to be a
little bit of a dick
and when i first met grant cardone he
was i thought he was the sweetest
kindest
most present but i was i was shocked at
how you know how much time he had for me
and how he just sat and chatted after
the interview and he was really
connecting me to some people so much so
that you know i went on some of his
programs i paid a couple hundred
thousand pounds to get some mentoring
and stuff and i found grant to to be
honest i found him i don't know i don't
know what your what your history is but
i've found granted i sadly didn't have
the same experience um i've always kind
of wanted to do over with grant because
i i very much respect what he does in
the world and for entrepreneurs but i i
sadly didn't have the same experience
when i met him uh here's i'll give the
quick story because we're dancing around
it right so why not i've told the story
on my podcast um i booked grant to speak
before grant
was as big as he was now i booked him to
speak at an event in 2015.
and grant like to his credit he helped
he promoted the event he was incredibly
kind and edifying in the lead up to the
event um edifying of our process and our
team fund would be very genuine and kind
we had three conversations about what we
were gonna talk about
um and he
said he was gonna kind of customize it
for that audience
when he got to the event he was
different um
he was very different he the fir
said some things that i didn't
appreciate on stage uh forgot all the
talking points that we had talked about
um
and just said said some things to me and
my team that i didn't appreciate at all
um
my everyone else says that they had a
very different experience with grant so
i've always wanted sort of a do-over
with him and i'm sure he and i will
cross paths on the stage on the stage
scene at some point
because i've always admired him and
really liked his his message and what he
does to represent capitalists in the
world
so
so um that's been my experience you can
tell i'm flustered a little bit talking
about this because he was one of those
people that i i really admired and when
i met him in person we just didn't i
didn't have the same experience you did
sam
or maybe he had
an off day or or whatever i guess
everyone's human but no i've had really
good experience i think he's got a great
heart
i'm sure there are people out there in
the world who have met me in person and
said what a dick
you know and it could have been because
of a bad day or because of something
that was going on because people would
have definitely said it in the wrong way
or whatever people have definitely said
that about me for sure
you know 100
but um but yeah so yeah garrett gary as
well gary's gary's a a great guy and
it's good to have these you know people
that that champion entrepreneurship in
the way they do and another thing i have
to say though there's a talking of
online marketing and creating products
and gary and grant and obviously we're
also in the you know sort of similar
space i guess you could say uh whatever
you want to call influencers bloggers
youtubers whatever um
the the industry of creating money and
creating wealth even though it's a very
wholesome thing you know creating money
is a wholesome thing it's a good thing
you said that in america you said to me
off camera that there's a little bit of
negativity around
money making entrepreneurship and stuff
like that i think you said um
i'm not sure if you said that maybe
maybe i misunderstood in britain it's a
whole nother level you know
i don't know what i've been to the
states a few times when i've been to the
states they they love success they love
business
maybe maybe i'm just comparing it to
britain um you know in in you know you
see those tick tock that there's that in
america they'll stop people in the
streets man they'll be like cool car
what do you do for a living you know in
in britain that never happens
if you stop somebody it never happens if
you if you stop someone
you wouldn't be able to stop someone in
a ferrari they wouldn't stop because
they'd assume you were coming to hate on
them they would drive off
in america it's like you know you come
over with the cameras hey hey dude and
they'll stop and they're like oh yeah
yeah
in england they would they would speak
they would put their foot down true
story i don't think i've ever ever seen
a video in the uk
one of those what do you do for a living
nice house
wow what are you i don't think i've ever
seen it happen
ever in britain oh wow ever so
i think
our industry
does have
some spammy scammy
you know a lot of i mean i mean i'm i'm
i run a training company as well so i'm
a property investor i also have a
training company in fact we're the
biggest
property or real estate education
company in the uk probably in europe so
you know we have a lot of a lot of um
students and we've got a good reputation
you know we're very a very very good
company and we absolutely go above and
beyond for our students
however
the industry in general the training
teaching people about money it
definitely does attract
some very europe you know sort of get
rich quickie people that probably talk
more than they've actually done
um showing off fancy lifestyles
lamborghinis that have probably been
rented you can do this too if you do my
course type thing and i am not at all
against um
education companies i mean i have one
myself i run an education company um
but what what what do you think about
that what because you're especially as
you're teaching people to market
themselves online and create products
are you part of that problem
yeah i mean it's a good i love that
question
i'm i'm open
people have accused me of that
right and i love to feel those questions
but the truth is
the scammy part of any industry is
actually a necessary entry point into
where the value is
now i'm not talking about scamming from
a perspective of fraud
i mean the hypey
fake part of things is actually often a
first step into industries here's an
example that will make crystallize this
nfts right now
nfts are a big speculative bubble
they're
currently
just
crappy art pieces that people are
flipping and trading
it's a it is a it's an asset bubble
it is going a lot of it is going to go
to zero
but this is a necessary part of the
evolution of this technology
and that technology nft technology will
absolutely revolutionize everything that
you and i do our membership programs
will be nft based in a few years
our everything that we purchase will be
done unchained and will give us a record
that will become an asset
it will absolutely revolutionize
everything we do
this scammy period is actually part of
what builds the foundation of that
internet marketing was no different
there was a big wide open west of boom
where there was scammy looking sales
pages and easy money being made all over
the place and gurus that came and went
but it paved the way for things like
search engine optimization and
customer relationship management and
sales processes and webinars and
education companies
they're they we responded our education
companies were a response to a demand
for real education in a scammy world
and so there's always that speculative
period followed by a legitimization of
the industry that's where i like to
think that you and i play and every time
you and i make a mistake on the scammy
side of things our customers remind us
and they push us back to why we are here
and to what we are building and it's our
incentive now to build a better way
forward and our
fault like the people who come after us
they'll be incentivized to create an
even better way than we could that's
capitalism it is the pioneering of new
industries and then improving them over
time and so i sometimes get lumped into
those scammy guys i'll take it it's part
of the industry it's part of the
territory when you put your name out
there in your face out there and you say
i have something for you that will
benefit you you're putting yourself in
the in the
way of people accusing you of that but
it's our job to do it better and better
it's interesting because some people
genuinely like i see in the comments
think that if you have a course
you are a scam artist yeah sure it's
like it's like some people will watch me
and they'll watch some videos and then
they'll be like oh my goodness guys i
just found out
he has a training
course
i knew he was trying to make money right
i feel
i feel so let down and disappointed i
thought this guy
literally was doing youtube videos and
this that and the other and and now he's
got a course it it
it makes everything illegitimate
you know some people think that for real
and there are other people who have told
me
hey i love to follow you but i stopped
because you didn't have a course that i
could buy that actually helped me do
this so it was like just about the you
show right
so you're never gonna be able to please
everybody
because when i started my training
company i mean i was literally um i was
literally doing it for free
from nothing else than
the love the joy the networking
and it was only when people said to me
look man
what what
we need and they were then going off on
other people's courses that i was like
that's not really a very good course
actually i'm disservicing
these people by not providing a valuable
um a to z step-by-step course i'm
actually disturbing them but there is
definitely a lot of the the lamborghini
sort of nothing wrong with lamborghinis
but i don't have a lamborghini i mean
i'm i'm quite i'm quite i'm not a flash
person you don't seem super flash either
i've made it made a lot of money and i
make a lot of money in real estate but i
have a nice house i have a good guy i
have a range rover car it massages me
it's got fridge in it but
but it's not like bling bling
you know i don't wear jewelry i don't
wear bling-bling type clothes um and i
don't know how many people do people
actually buy into that i don't know i
mean but there is a lot of you know and
i think i think there's a lot of people
um you know sort of around about 20 2019
2020 they've started calling out
the the the fakers
but then realized that actually this is
a really good way
to get to get views
because people love nothing more more
than loving
the idea of how to get a lamborghini
they also love hearing about the guy
that the the the that is a faker so
suddenly you have the all these people
creating videos
trying to get traffic
saying this person's actually a fake
this person's actually a fake and other
people even doing videos about me saying
samuel they didn't know me they didn't
come on my course but they were just
saying oh actually he's a fake look at
this at the other and i challenge them
i'm like
let's have a debate about this sure i'd
love for you to come on my channel and
only one guy did
sam there's um
this is me the most controversial thing
that i say in our entire time together
are you ready
go for it the person who changed my mind
on a lot of this was tai lopez
so so tai lopez i i knew tai before here
in my garage before he had a youtube
channel before he had a following yeah
and tai was in incredibly insightful
and very smart
before he was a guru right he was
successful way before then
and when his audience just grew out of
nowhere when he just came out of the
scene and exploded
i i sat down with him and said like what
did you do here and he essentially said
i knew my market which was guys who were
under 25 mostly single
and i knew it would get their attention
which was
girls and lamborghinis
and so i used girls and lamborghinis as
a proxy to get them to pay attention to
the message that i had for them
and knowing tai like i know him his life
is what he describes his life to be yeah
and he is extremely underrated in our
space he owns dress barn he owns pier
one he i mean he owns everything
and
and he walks what
he shares
and and and so he adjusted my opinion
just slightly on this
that sometimes going for the attention
can be in service to some people not
everybody it's going to turn people off
there's plenty of tai lopez haters which
is great like they'll follow you and me
yeah but tai serves his audience in a
very unique way tai though i don't know
tai personally i don't know him well um
but tai will also
happily have debates with people
about what he's done
about his about his programs and i think
i did watch a long time ago i did watch
one um he
was like yeah come on and he brought
some some online hater on on his show
and i thought respect because you know
for me i think that's really important
being able to debate your point you know
if you if you found some cowboy on
instagram that was saying i've got a lot
i've got this
and he wasn't the real deal would he
really voluntarily have a debate with
somebody
right
no he wouldn't so for me i think that's
quite
a a tell a telltale sign of whether
someone is legit or not it's like how
long have they been going
what have they actually done have they
got success students will they publicly
debate
about you know i think these are all
good signs but there are bad in the
industry but i guess as you said that's
kind of
the evolutionary part to to anything
good and with any industry you've got
good and you've got bad um what's your
reasoning what what what why why are you
doing this why did you agree to this
interview why are you
pushing capitalism.com what's the what's
the what's the underlying reason
it's my genuine belief
that entrepreneurship and capitalism
is the most effective way to create
change it will always be this way it
always has been this way since the
advent of capitalism
and so
the the
the pursuit
of wealth
the entrepreneurial journey
is a proxy to create better people to
create better products to create more
service to one another and i believe
that it's the most loving system
the most creative system the most
abundant system and we never need more
government we need more freedom and more
capitalism and so i love hanging out
with other entrepreneurs who are doing
what you and i do
of helping create change through freedom
and through capitalism
awesome well on that note we'll wrap up
because we've been going a long time but
um but ryan i really appreciate your
time um anyone watching i would highly
recommend checking out ryan's website
capitalism.com i'll leave a link in the
in the description can i give one quick
plug sam go ahead bro so we spent a few
minutes at the top of the call talking
about that that formula of four products
25 sales a day 30 that's a million
dollar business that is most of our work
at capitalism.com is helping
entrepreneurs follow that process
so if you heard sam say that you need to
have your fast cash and your slow cash
and real estate is your slow cash it's
your long-term play to produce passive
income and long-term wealth but you're
saying
what is going to be
the entrepreneurial side of this that is
going to be the business that pays me
that i can build and sell that's what we
help people do best place to start is my
book you can torrent it if you can buy
it on kindle i don't care or steal it
from the library
it's called 12 months to 1 million and
it's about plugging in that formula four
products 25 sales sales a day at a 30
price point
12 months to 1 million that's my book
good goal
good title
good book damn i i'm inspired just at
the title i think that's um
done hundreds of times million dollar
business in 12 months it can absolutely
be done amazing well ryan will be sure
to check out the book i'll leave a link
i'll leave that in the description as
well and uh thanks once again for your
time and look forward to hopefully doing
something again real soon great to see
you sam thanks so much for having me on
i appreciate you peace out